This episode is sponsored by Squarespace.
Go to Squarespace.com/microcosmos to save
10% off your first purchase of a website or domain.
Hi, I’m Matt, and I’m not really new here.
I’ve been a producer for Journey to the
Microcosmos from the very beginning,
editing videos for the first
few years of the channel and
keeping our journey
running smoothly.
And some of you maybe have
even seen me in our livestreams.
But this is new, right?
Me, talking to you all?
I’ll probably be around a bit more along
with some other new voices as our usual voice,
Hank, takes some time to take care of himself.
So our journey will sound a bit different,
maybe even look a bit different at times.
But every journey has to take unfamiliar paths,
and we hope you’ll be able to enjoy this
one with us.
And like I said, I spent the first few years
of this channel editing the videos together,
and in that time, I’ve gotten so much better
at identifying our microbial friends than
I ever would have imagined.
Like these organisms.
Before I worked on this show, if you’d asked
me what they are, I maybe would have told
you that they look like some long threads.
But we’ve seen them quite a bit now, watching
them glide across our slides as we talk about
their sediment homes.
And that’s how I know that these are a type
of bacteria called Beggiatoa
There’s a few things that give them away.
First is the simple serpentine shape of
their bodies, sliding against each other like
a pile of pythons buried on a microscopy slide.
The second detail that identifies them as
Beggiatoa are those little dots inside of them.
They look like bubbles, but they’re actually
sulfur granules.
So why do our Beggiatoa friends stuff themselves
full of sulfur?
To understand that, we have to first talk
about where they live.
James, our master of microscopes, usually
finds his Beggiatoa at the bottom of his fish
tank, where their accumulated bodies turn
the sediment white.
And in the wild, Beggiatoa can be found in
both freshwater and marine environments,
layering themselves upon
each other to form mats
that can end up looking
like nature’s weirdest shag rug.
They gather in the area of water that will
give them the access they need to particular
nutrients, but…
what does that mean exactly?
We all like to live in a spot that gives us
the access we need to particular nutrients,
but we don’t all form clumps and mats on
the bottom of fish tanks.
So what is it about their particular location
that particularly suits the Beggiatoa?
The answer came in the year 1887 from a scientist
named Sergei Winogradsky.
Winogradsky is sometimes credited with discovering
Beggiatoa, but from what we’ve read, scientists
had been describing and studying Beggiatoa
before he did.
In 1870, one researcher described the fact
that those granules would increase in number
when the Beggiatoa was in its normal habitat.
There was something about these sulfur granules
that made sense given that these Beggiatoa
were found in sulfur-rich environments, like
sulfur springs.
And when other scientists began to look at
bacteria in those environments, they
found similar granules.
But the creation and purpose of those granules
remained unclear.
Winogradsky did not first encounter Beggiatoa
with the intention of solving those mysteries.
In 1885, he began working for the botanist
Anton de Bary at the University of Strassburg.
The question that Winogradsky was initially
meant to pursue revolved around the shape
of bacteria, and really just how fixed that
shape is.
To answer that question, Winogradsky began
traveling around Switzerland and Germany to
gather Beggiatoa growing in sulfur springs.
But then he got a bit distracted and wandered
down a different path.
Winogradsky needed to figure out how to keep
the Beggiatoa he was studying alive in the
lab, so he grew them in tiny little cultures
and watched as the Beggiatoa filaments stuck
to the side of their chambers.
He would wash them with various fluids with
different compositions, and as he watched
them, he could begin to see what nutrients
best sustained the Beggiatoa.
And as he watched, Winogradsky’s curiosity
around the sulfur granules grew as he asked
more and more questions about how they got
inside the organisms, and what their role is.
In one of his experiments, Winogradsky kept
different batches of cells in different types
of spring water, and then monitored them under
the microscope.
He found that the cells grown in the presence
of hydrogen sulfide would end up full of those
sulfur granules.
But cells grown in spring water full of calcium
sulfate didn’t.
That experiment showed that the Beggiatoa
were getting their sulfur granules by oxidizing
hydrogen sulfide.
This also explains how the bacteria find their
ideal spot in the water, a narrow band where
hydrogen sulfide and oxygen are both present,
and that allows Beggiatoa access to both chemicals
they need to form those sulfur granules.
But this still didn’t explain what the Beggiatoa
do with the sulfur granules.
Winogradsky could see that when the Beggiatoa
were deprived of hydrogen sulfide, those granules
would disappear…
so where did they go?
Were they released into the environment?
Were they absorbed by the cell in some way?
What was the point of the sulfur?
What Winogradsky found is that the sulfur
was essentially food for the Beggiatoa, fueling
their cellular respiration.
This was the first ever description of what
would later be known as chemolithotrophy,
and it was groundbreaking.
It meant that Winogradsky had found an organism
that could draw energy from an inorganic compound—
in this case, using sulfur to drive the reactions
it needs to produce energy.
Eventually, scientists discovered more organisms
that could use sulfur in this way, as well
as others that relied on different inorganic
compounds like nitrogen.
And in doing so, they are able to convert
these chemicals into biological forms that
can travel through ecosystems and then back
into the environment.
For sulfur, that journey will take it through
many lives, as part of rocks and amino acids
and even acid rain, transforming our lives
and landscapes in the process.
Organisms like Beggiatoa usher sulfur through
that odyssey, a mundane act of consumption
that shapes our entire world.
And so perhaps it's fitting to end with Winogradsky’s
own words, a moment from his memoir where
he describes the moment of discovery.
The work was humdrum, it dragged on and on
sluggishly, and all of a sudden it developed
into an interesting result and was finished.
All the beating around suddenly made sense,
and I matured in my own eyes.
Even so, I could not see that my discovery
would become an epoch-making discovery,
would determine the course of all my future work,
and that it would open a new chapter in microbiology
and physiology.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you to Squarespace for sponsoring
this episode.
Squarespace offers an incredible online platform
from which to create your website.
Whether you're a budding entrepreneur or looking
to expand your current venture, Squarespace
provides all the necessary tools to help you
thrive.
Maybe you have a passion for gourmet baking
and want to establish an impressive online
presence for your bakery.
Squarespace enables you to craft a visually
stunning and professional website that showcases
your delectable creations and embodies your
unique brand.
With their comprehensive suite of features,
including third-party extensions, you can
effortlessly manage your inventory, simplify
bookkeeping, and ship your baked goods worldwide.
And if you also want to share your baking
journey and engage with fellow baking enthusiasts,
Squarespace makes it a breeze to create a
seamlessly integrated blog alongside your
bakery's online store.
You can captivate your readers by sharing
your latest recipes, baking tips, and behind-the-scenes
insights into your creative process.
And you can engage in meaningful conversations
with your clientele through threaded comments
and replies, cultivating a passionate community
of baking enthusiasts.
Start building your online bakery today by
signing up for a free trial at Squarespace.com.
And when you're ready to launch, don't forget
to visit squarespace.com/microcosmos to enjoy
a 10% discount on your first purchase of a
website or domain.
Experience the power of Squarespace and watch
your bakery business rise to new heights.
Those names you're seeing on the screen right
now are names of our Patreon patrons.
They are some of the people who support this
channel and keep it going,
So, if you enjoy the fact that this show has
existed for four years now, you can drop a
little thank you in the comments to those
Patreon patrons, but you can also become one
of them and support the channel directly at
Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
If you'd like to see more from our Master
of Microscopes James Weiss, you can check
out Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you'd like to see more from us, well,
there's probably a subscribe button somewhere
nearby, probably below the video or on the
screen right now.
One of those two.
Just click it.
Check that it works.